all right
hello there uh let's see this is a
language completeness and consistency
meeting about various new directions in
wolfram language
it looks like our first topic is formal
operators
so this is a continuation of our
discussion from last time
where you had some
idea of some sort of compound
expression that could represent an
operator
um and then
right then we could add tagging
information and
i'm not sure we got much more than yes
and somehow
we could make this all magically work
but
well i think the situation we're in
right now
is that we have these specific formal
variables
like formal a right
we don't have a formal plus
we believe that in a sense
what we're trying to do is to have
things that have a symbolic presence
without a meaning like a plus sign
that is symbolically like a plus sign
but it doesn't have a meaning
but it does have a syntax
that seems to be one of the things we're
trying to achieve
right so i mean in other words there are
constructs with syntax
and form but no meaning
okay actually was there a notebook from
last time i feel like we created a
notebook last time
but yeah i thought we'd had two um
uh addison i don't recall it it might be
in the functional programming folder
but there's a lot of stuff in there uh
can you sort by most recent
no if not i i i could try to find it and
i'll just send it in twitch chat
formal
show one there was a person
somebody on the mailing list had
suggested if we're having all these
formal constructs
um um
and instead of having dots we should
have bow ties
but i'm going to ignore that that
conceptual pun
um i think we do have a bow tie
don't we have a bow tie we don't have a
bow tie
what do we call it okay
in case so constructs with syntax and
form but no meaning
okay and we had discussed
a bunch of things in connection with
this the issue is
you know do the operators
have known precedence
right because that's what we did in
version three back in the mid 1990s
right we have this idea of you know a
you know whatever it is circle plus
b and that has
you know circle times
c right and that has known precedence
right with the circle times having
higher precedence
right but now you might say well in my
wacky theory of
of uh you know
operoids in my theory of operoids i want
it to be the other way around
but that's presumably not what we're
signing up for
the question is what are we signing up
for well
i could imagine something that's called
formal that just
takes you know
formal abcd
that is like a symbol
well and and we also discussed last time
the possibility of symbol
um um
okay you're being told i'm being told
that there is a previous
notebook here um
tip for next time we should know that
before we start the meeting
equation solving for subscripted
variables formal operators
okay
right
we discussed two formal expression
okay what is this
what is this concept here uh well that
was your concept so
um but right you right so you were
talking at some point about
somehow using right just like we have
you know tilde that can sort of turn any
symbol into a
you know super high priority super high
precedence
uh infix operator that we could have
some way of constructing these
uh you know have some representation of
of these formal operators right because
we might need more than one plus or more
than one times
right so okay so so then what we could
imagine
i mean okay so an extreme version is
um right so i think the formal operator
of plus
xxx right that's formal plus
right that's a representation of plus
with you know whatever metadata about
the theory it belongs to
and then it's arguments so here's a
bizarre idea
okay here's a bizarre idea
let's say i'm just going to write this
out as you know whatever it is
random unicode character that's that's a
dangerous
uranium 235 unicode character let's use
uter35
um let's imagine
that um i'm just sort of
oops um
okay let's imagine that
a character can be encased in unicode
characters
and that that
composite symbol name
oh no actually let me take a different
example
um this thing here would be an encased
plus
that has syntactic rules that have for
example a different operator precedence
and it would display
like a lightly annotated ordinary plus
but if you looked at the full form
i mean i don't know what these these are
probably private unicode characters
i would have some different form is this
completely bonkers
well i
it's not entirely clear to me what
you're suggesting which might
okay so hold on hold on so what i'm
suggesting is this i'm trying to make
a way to have an operator that looks
that walks and talks like plus
but acts different from plus and you
mean
act by what do you mean what do you mean
by acts different
its full form parsed representation is
something completely different
perhaps it would be fall operator
quotes plus you know precedence level
244 2442 xyz
okay um
i mean you could certainly
i mean starting from that
full form you could format it as
something that looks like
plus with that precedence although
precedence is
out of the thousands so you know it
wouldn't be
you know i don't know how you would turn
i don't know how editable that would be
or if you could turn it into something
that could
uh okay so look look one of the
questions here is
what we have we have inactive
well that's an act of eight which
produces and then i know in this case
right
the real question is to what extent do
we want to piggyback
on our existing notations and things on
a keyboard
but give them different meanings
and towards the start and let me point
out that you can't type in
that two plus two there that that out of
12.
i mean if if it exists if that
particular plus sign exists somewhere in
your notebook you can copy and paste it
and you know as long as you don't hit
any of the 17 edge cases i know about
it will work correctly but that's not
something
you can just type in from scratch
so what about the possibility
that there is something like a
two-formal expression
where what you do whatever our
representation is
this two formal expression of a plus b
equals c right and we considered this
last time and we abandoned it because
a it didn't you know it seems like it
might be too aggressive
like what if there's something in there
you don't want to turn into formal
and b you know if you have more than one
plus sign how does it know which plus
would have to have some mapping but i
have to say
i mean in a sense this is like just
define a parser
at some level we might as well just say
you know define an arbitrary parser
okay i mean the thing i'm still coming
back to is
what peop okay the experiment from the
1990s of providing circle plus and
things like that from people
was not terribly successful in my
opinion
i thought those things would get used
all the time just like okay so here's
the analogy
which which didn't play out okay you
know
here's the question user behavior
question mark do people
pick operators like they pick variable
names
i i think i will disagree with you there
i think it's successful the problem is
that we have too few
for example imagine that we want to do
module theory
so we need a sum for vectors and a sum
for scalars
we only have sql plus so why not having
like
square plus and dot plus
and various of those
okay i think okay so this is the
okay so look this is a fundamental
question which i hadn't really
internalized this way before
people have no trouble picking variable
names you know they may do it better
they may do it worse
but they pick variable names right
the question is can they pick operator
name can they pick up
and the variables you know in a first
approximation they've got
single character you know strings for
those variable names
are making sense so in a sense they've
got 26 possible variables
but they know there's an escape valve
right so the next question would be do
they
pick you know you're saying jose
there aren't enough that the number of
of
of these is too small
compared to whatever right and i think
this whole discussion comes from
we trying to do more things in axiomatic
theory and running out of symbols
yes there is a there's a straightforward
if somewhat an elegant solution to that
which would be if we have
a formal operator wrapper as i believe
was discussed last time
then we could just nest that arbitrarily
many times and
obtain arbitrarily many formal operators
with the same base symbol like
plus sure but how would you type it in
i mean so if the if the behavior is
formal operator
of quotes plus i think it's exactly what
we had up here formal operator
quotes plus whatever that that is
we can certainly do that
it's
ah let me think about this i'm just
pointing out that i mean if we want an
escape valve that is a
that is an obvious one uh if a slightly
verbose one
yeah right but the problem is the reason
people like using
x as a variable name is because it's you
know small and easy to type
and another thing that michael pointed
out i use you know camel case words as
my variable
names and you know so and i only type in
the first
you know two or three characters because
you know i have auto complete
okay so here's a crazy idea we could
have an escape key version
of formal operator plus 242 that will be
something like
escape plus semicolon number
that could create that object that box
object
perhaps it's crazy but i mean then then
then
you've got this kind of weird situation
where oh that was a 242
plus there and oh i've got these two
theories and i really want those pluses
to be the same plus well i guess you can
always say
formal operator of plus comma 241 goes
to 242.
um
um
so is the 241 a tag or a precedence
i was thinking it was a precedence i
mean
right oh well right but that's a detail
right i mean it could be
right we could have an association with
you know precedence and
uh i'm not sure how much we could change
and
maybe associativity or and extra tags
and whatnot
but your basic claim is there are too
few characters here
that was a basic claim being made i i
think
the for the fundamental operators plus
and times plus we only have one which is
sql plus
and times we have like two or three
uh yeah and we need more
equals we have like three so perhaps
with equal which was the
first one we started discussing we have
well okay so let's compare this
okay how do we get in in character data
don't remember how to extract out
mathematical symbols and character data
what is it called do you know what i'm
talking about
the the um um now we
i think we have a character name and
then we have a character entity
oh yeah right
okay so what what we're talking about is
to select
from the unicode things a place where
the character entity is mathematical
symbol can somebody figure out how to do
that
so we can just get a big table of all
mathematical symbols in unicode
uh well uh that depends on your
definition of mathematical symbol which
is also part of the problem right
because some symbols are are
letter like and some are operators and
and those are
right well so um okay we can go
let's see i wonder whether my i wonder
how many more people i i adopted the ram
character last christmas just for fun
um in the adopt a character program
uh you've already heard me you guys have
already heard me talk about
adopting the ram character which was the
um okay let's take a look here
where do they have their help where is
their actual unicode table
code charts
okay here we go
so let's take a look
so what they don't define here where is
the where is
where is math help
where's math
mathematical operators
okay so unicode has no lack of weird
mathematical operators
right right and i guess the question is
do we treat these all as operator
operators
and the answer is probably not john
might know better but
it is so let's i don't think john is
here but let's see
yeah yeah i'm here um and
no they're not they're not all strictly
yeah that's treated as a letter-like
form there
so i think the default is to treat them
with letter like form so one
yeah if we if we don't have a long name
for it that's what we do
right so one change we could make is to
treat
unicode treat the mathematical operators
section of unicode
as operators
but then the problem is what unicode
does not define
for these operators is what their
precedence or where they appear
in other words this puppy for example
here
is presumably a you know
a less than not equal to a subset
you know a subset not equal thing
which we presumably think is a binary
operator with certain precedence
but for example if you take uh
well certainly infinity there is not an
operator for our purposes
right and uh yeah i know and so null set
there two two zero
five that's presumably not an operator
right but it's a little bit weird
i mean that could be a circle slash or
it could be a null set i don't know
which one it is
no it you you look it up uh down below
uh there's a textual description and
at the end of the fight yeah no i know
so it says it's the null set
okay so that's not an operator
um and you know some of these
are you know the nre co-product it's
presumably a prefix operator
so the question really what one one
thing that could be on the table
i mean i don't know that anybody has
curated the unicode math operators i
mean we were involved with the unicode
math operators back in the 90s but
i don't know whether anybody has curated
these
to say
what their you know what
are they prefix infects et cetera et
cetera et cetera but their semantic
purposes yeah but we don't necessarily
care about that
right actually i i think it's well i
mean
you know if it's operatorness it's in
fixedness i mean
those are semantic properties
yes but i think for users we should
create like we have circle times we
should have like
square plus and we don't we don't care
about what
the mathematical meaning is because if
we cared that would be our symbol
like for example we have circle dot for
the users we have permutation product
for us
we have wedge for the users tensor wedge
for us
etc
and what's your point jose i don't i
don't quite get the point here
are you saying that tensor which does
tensor wedge have an infix form
yes yes escape t
t uh carrot escape
right so compare that compare tensor
wedge to which
okay so they have similar
type setting but the wedges for the
users
and potentially for us in axiomatic
theory etc
and but tensor which is our symbol
so you're saying one symbol is named
after it's shape
and the other is named more after its
functionality exactly
so for example we have that uh like
capital delta
which is the letter like versus
difference delta
which is an operator right
or sql plus is for the users and
eventually we might have a direct
sum or something like that for us to do
the right thing with tensors and
vector spaces
so so what i'm saying is that what we
need is more of these
shape symbols like square plus there's a
nice square
plus they are near the end of that table
that thing that one
i would recognize that this is a plus
like i would guys i didn't think it was
a plus i didn't think of that
but okay so so jose's proposal is
quote shaped up character operators
right and they can be used for whatever
purpose and another important thing here
that michael pointed out
is that if we go the formal route they
will be
naturally protected while these shaped
characters are usually
are genetically not protected and users
define
algebraic rules for them is is that a
shaped character that one there
two two five eight i guess
we have a ham equal i don't think we
have that particular one but we
certainly have like dot equal
and um some of these other equals
well say jose is denying my claim that
our efforts in the 1990s were
unsuccessful with respect to things like
dot equal
what about things like long equal we
that that oh we do have that as
i didn't know that doesn't exist i i i
i if if that exists i i claim that's a
bug
and an artifact of the fact that there
is a character called long equal
which parses to equal i see okay
but but what if you actually want a long
equal i mean this is the
okay so you're saying that these forms
which don't evaluate
but do have every other they walk and
talk happily
in other ways they just don't happen to
evaluate
right
and certainly we get every now and then
bug reports of
or you know requests from users you know
could you add
this guy and can you add that guy
um which i mean it's
it's you don't have a super great
workflow for doing this so it's a bit
obnoxious to join what
for for creating a character because we
need to create a long name and
parsing sure it's a it's a thing i mean
we haven't really done it in large scale
since the 1990s we've done it in one you
know individual pieces
that we've needed for various kinds of
things like you know distributed like or
whatever else
right yeah yeah i'm not saying that my
only point is that there's nothing
intrinsically difficult about this it's
just
you know it requires coordination and
because we don't do it very often
the the incremental cost is high that
that's all i'm saying
all right so one possibility if we could
drive down the incremental cost and then
add every single one that we get a
request for well or just
add them preemptively i mean so one
proposal that's on the table is just
add a bunch more so use the fact
see okay let's i don't ever see people
using symbol names maybe greek letters
but nothing more ornate than that
i mean very very occasionally i will see
somebody
just for fun using my friend
this guy as a symbol name
i've been known to use smiley face and
and sad faces
as variables yes i know that's that's a
thing
people do that from time to time but
i mean usually i mean that the you know
we don't tell a story
you know right uh in
you know we're not writing hieroglyphic
whatever's you know
right it's mostly roman greek and
occasionally hebrew
right but also hebrew is very
i i mean i doubt well maybe you do you
know aleph
abc maybe you say that i don't know
i mean i do that sort of thing for for
for testing purposes but certainly
right alef and bet have have
well-defined meanings and so
sure as individual characters yes but
but okay but i mean so the basic point
is
what i'm what i'm addressing is user
behavior users routinely use
words or or
or kind of truncated words as symbol
names
yep right the question is will
users routinely use a thing that looks
like that
as an operator
a thing which like this this thing i
don't know how to describe that thing
you know but i could use it as an
operator in principle it's like i could
pick it off the
palette and say that looks cool i'll use
it as an operator
well i think people do this when they're
writing mathematical packages
right if they use something where it's
traditional doing some
writing a package for you know abstract
algebra
then they may use circle plus and and
circle times and circle dot
as their to define their operations
indeed in exactly we use several of
these to define the various algebraic
operations
okay well
but you're saying if we introduced them
into axiomatic theory for example
that that would be on i mean as we have
done using silica plus in circle times i
mean do we think that's successful in
axioratic theory
or are we upset that those things aren't
a genuine plus i mean
are we happy if in module theory or
whatever we have a
circle plus and we have a square plus
and we just have to
write in the documentation um
the uh
um i think the the current axiomatic
theory setup works
fine it's just as as we say as jose says
we just don't have enough symbols
i agree and as a consequence we
occasionally
have to use slightly weird symbols where
in you know in places where it would be
better if we had a different one
okay so
what about the zero tilde so that's
that's another
annotation is yeah
that's that's formal zero if you like
yes
what if there was decoration that you
could do on an operator
and still have it act as an operator
would that be useful let's say you could
tildify or
put a bar or dot or something on an
operator and have it still act like the
operator it was
does that make sense to people well we
would have wanted
i mean i suppose it depends on what you
mean by
act like the operator it was presumably
it should parse to something else
right yeah to this new thing i see
okay so then then you're basically
saying yeah it can't
it can't act exactly the same you i mean
you know
a plus b plus c is a is a flat plus
a plus dot b plus c
there's got to be some distinction there
well okay so
okay so one possible strategy is
we keep the formal varric but you know
we keep these formal variable things as
we have them right now
and we simply add more operators that's
that's one possible path
i mean one thing i find frustrating is
just
typing in long formula with formal
variables it's just an incredible pain
you know what would help us to have them
a palette
although then then it's like finger
typing you know it's like one finger
typing
there
um of course they are in a palette
but the formal the formal symbols um
are they under letters i'm pretty sure
they are
what do you know i didn't know that
done something new every day
hmm but you know most of the time i just
type backslash back at formal a which is
a big pain in the neck to type
worse if you wanted a capital yeah
but so i mean that raises the question
do we want something
i mean look we can have a functional
positive function that quotes formalizes
an expression
it's kind of a hacky thing good for the
function repository
um
okay well so where are we going with
this so if we were to introduce more
operators
we'll need precedence for all of them
names and precedence same thing that i
did back in the
when was it 94 95
time frame i went through what i did at
that time was i went through
in those days a bunch of books you know
looking at what the effective precedence
of different operators was
and finding a high degree of consistency
in the way they were used
but that would have to be redone right
for additional operators
not making sense
although i mean we do sort of share
press
a lot of press fences right like equal
less
less equal all have the same precedence
so we could you know say all the pluses
well all the decorated pluses have the
same precedence
yeah okay that would help i mean if
that's we should look at whether that's
what typical mathematical
mathematical usage actually is
um well this is an interesting idea
okay that we that we basically try and
name
another 20 30
kind of things like the circle plus that
we've had from since the 1990s i mean in
a sense
this is good news because it means that
the direction we went to the 1990s
wasn't foolish
it just wasn't far enough
and uh if we're going to be adding more
of these uh there's uh it's not super
flushed out but in the agenda i do have
a little note
about um circle plus
uh but i i can explain it more orally
that there's some weirdness with these
guys
so i think yeah so circle times
is documented to be prefix or
infects and both the kernel and front
end
agree on this possibility these four
other characters none of them is
they're all documented to be infix only
but either the front end or the kernel
but not both
thinks one of you know each one of these
can be either
insects or prefix so i think i think
it's probably
going along the lines of you know plus a
works as does a plus b
right so that's so what you were saying
is circle plus
a that looks really ugly
well that thinks it's the center of
sound kernel doesn't know this
i mean i think it would be reasonably
easy to fix this
now that i'm aware of this but
yeah i guess circle minor yeah i was a
little surprised by circle minus but i
guess
minus can be insects or physics also so
well so this is an interesting idea to
essentially grandfather
the i like this idea this this brings
some order to the whole
bizarre situation right to grandfather
to decide it's a decorator
and so so the principle is
all decorated operators
porous like their
undecorated forms
are syntactically like their undecorated
forms
behave syntactically
okay that's an interesting idea
okay and then then some of these guys
would get a base undecorated form like
that weird creature
what is its base undecorative form two
to b6
so it to be clear that code point should
not be used as a generic thing because
it has a specific meaning what what do
you mean
i i i mean in unicode it has a specific
meaning it's not just a pretty picture
wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute wait a minute the circle plus
two two two two b6
yeah okay where is 2g b6
bit further
i don't i'm not good at my sorting
and
original of an image of
see look so i mean i mean of course we
can invent our own but
my only point is that uh uh
you know we should only ascribe generic
meaning to
official unicode code points that
you know themselves suggest they're
intended to be used for
generic meaning
which circle plus for example is and
square plus and triangle plus
isn't this a case of size like like
tensor weights on which
they look the same but but they have
different size
but here here i'm referring to code
points you know we can always throw
something in private space and we can
make it look like whatever we want and
i'm not going to complain about any of
that
i just don't want to use a unicode code
point
that uh you know that has a different
meaning
from the one that we're a scorpio okay
so what your claiming is
i think what you're claiming is that
squared minus is generic
left tac is generic
but normal subgroup of isn't generic
that's right and how do we pick between
these
uh i i mean to the to the extent that we
can you know we discern it from the
description in the unicode spec itself
and which is
you know what we're doing here
so this thing here is does not prove
but this thing here is right tech yeah
that's really weird
see right tack as they say here proves
implies yields
well and even stranger you know 22a9
versus 22aaa
you know 22a9 is forces 22aa is
triple vertical bar right turn style you
know
um
you know where 22aaa is kind of seems
fairly clearly generic 22a9 is not
are you saying this i mean this is
look the fact is there will be a math
paper that uses this triple whatsit
to mean you know forces transfinitely or
something
sure but that's that's you know
i mean that's your call it's not a thing
that
the unicode that the unicode spec is
suggesting at all
so you can assign whatever meaning you
want to do it
but what are you suggesting here you're
suggesting we go through this and we
pick out those things which are
which have an appearance that is somehow
right so basically well i mean i mean i
mean we don't have to
stick to this list we can invent our own
that's fine
uh and then they would live in our
uh you know in our private unicode space
okay take pitchfork here is it proper
intersection or is it pitchfork
yeah so the you know when you see these
equal signs you know that's an
indication
that uh you know it tends to be used
for that but it's not you know
but but it's not absolutely and only
that
if you know what i mean okay but why
isn't this left triangle slash
rather than not normal subgroup of
because the unicode committee said so
okay well i'm pretty sure that this if i
look for this
yep that seems to be that one
okay i mean back in the day we were
involved with this very unicoding
process
so the reason i'm
you know concerned about this is because
you want to make sure that if you're
you know converting to mathml or tech or
whatever
you know that uh you know things that
have an ascribed meaning from the
unicode spec
you know that that you're consistent
about that when you're speaking
to the external world but we can't be
because we don't have
one day in the future we will have a not
normal subgroup of
oh god this is a mess i mean we could
take every unicode character like this
and you know okay circle plus well and
this is something we do you know i mean
every time we come up with an
operator that you know has some
specific meaning we want to ascribe to
it and and we search the unicode spec to
see if it exists
if so that's the code point we use if
not then we invent our
then you know we go to the private space
all right does somebody want to take a
crack at seeing whether there's a
reasonable expansion
yeah this is particularly among the
mathematical operators page this is the
single page two two
zero zero well it's the two teams well
and there's also a couple of extra
pages that are the supplemental a
supplemental b
or sorry miscellaneous or whatever it is
yeah
and is this including
the non-dnp or is that
for releasing only the bmp
[Music]
uh line zero the uh
uh so the the uh the character blocks
the main page of character blocks
includes everything
including non-bmp uh bmp is that plane
zero
uh yes it's the basic multilingual plane
okay but these are all less than 65k
boy there's some weird stuff here i mean
i remember when this was all being put
together
i mean there was a lot of crazy
whimsical stuff of people
who had these books that have been
collected of random notation and people
were just like oh yeah it looks like a
cool picture we'll put it in
so i think that the only
really math based stuff outside the
basic multilingual plane is
the uh mathematical alphanumeric symbols
which we don't care about for purposes
this discussion because it's
alphanumeric it's not operators well
unless
we use those as our formal variables
is that obviously stupid well uh
the i mean some of these are things that
uh currently sit in our private space
and
you know ought to one day be remapped i
mean you know the
the gothics and the and the double
strucks uh ought to be remapped into
this space
uh into which space into plain on
non-plane zero
yeah it just hasn't been done because we
haven't had full support for
for non-plane zero but which we are
getting real
soon right yeah yeah it's i mean the
kernel already has it the front end
you know has it has pieces of it um
um but you know that remapping is on the
roadmap
um so to speak also on the roadmap
is uh uh remapping
our mathematical greeks so that we can
distinguish
mathematical greeks from actual greek
language greeks yep
what's the compatibility well uh
the uh the good news is that uh
we use long names uh in all of our files
so uh generally no issues there
and we already have a compatibility
mechanism for mismatched
kernels and front ends we already have a
mechanism for you know old front end
speaking to new kernel or vice versa
um okay okay
um all right
the the big compatibility problem is
going to be
for once again for our poor
long-suffering greek users
but we just have to get over the hump
with them and then and then we'll be
well hopefully we can give them some
utilities but oh
yes absolutely okay so
let's let's zoom out here so by the way
i do want to push a little bit this
mathematical alpha numerics as a way to
do formal symbols
is that obviously crazy
i i i have no problem with it but i'm
not
the expert on formal usage so uh but
from from a unicode
point of view i have no problem with it
oh yeah i think we should think about
that
okay but then i i missed something what
are you asking about okay so i'm saying
so john is saying that in non-plane zero
unicode
there are mathematical alphanumeric
characters x y
z that are intended as math x y z
uh it's i i just uh posted the
link in chat so you can look at the
chart
it's the 1d 400 range
wow
cool this is useful
well you're proposing then okay so for
the greeks and so on fine that's all
dandy
yeah but
one of the nice things about this is
that you know there are
there are positions here for actual
italicized greek letters
exactly how we render them so so that's
nice
right but so something like this is that
supposed to for purposes of the kernel
map to a just a regular communal garden
bee
or is it it is it is i mean
it is definitely supposed to be you know
it renders specifically italic
and it is its own unicode code points
you know
never to be confused with a b with a
standard b
okay so one possibility would be to have
these characters be our formal
characters
because that way they have the advantage
that if somebody has
an external program we're not dealing
with private unicode space to render
these things
well if we're but then we can't reuse
them for our existing
double struct you know i mean maybe we
can
well no i'm suggesting there's different
kinds there's the gothics here
which would just be the gothic symbols
and if you set the value to them
then you cooked your own goose but
the ordinary alphabetics
actually there's a difference so they're
metallic alphabets yeah they're bolds
they're italics they're bold italics um
and then the the script which i think
would
be our gothics uh bold script
uh uh no they're not that's not gothic
that's not cool right there are actual
the frock tours
are oh yeah sorry the fractures are the
gothics um
uh or as alan turing used to say there
are
greek letters that he uses for some
things and in his papers he used
german letters for other things
that's something that's gone out of
style
doubles and double strucks even sans
serif you know
uh a bunch of ranges here that could be
co-opted for
some purpose okay it's unclear to me
what to do with these
so how would you type them in that's an
issue
[Music]
we should think about this i i don't
know what the answer to this is but it
seems like our more immediate thing
which is a fairly straight shot
design-wise
is adding decorated operators
and to see whether there's a decent set
of decorated operators that will be
useful for axiomatic theory
because i mean again there are operators
there
that i just don't think are
right wiggly fence
see the the question is right wiggly
fence
that thing there probably one of those
like like is that useful is it not
useful what on earth should it parse
like
yeah actually it's a fence so it
probably should pass like left
parse like left ceiling right ceiling
it's a matching
it's a matching operator yeah yeah
but i mean this notion which we need to
check that things parse and have the
precedence level
of their base undecorated form is at
least
an understandable theory
we need to check if it's correct
okay and you know they're only i mean
you know the official unicode variations
of say plus
minus times you know there aren't so
many but we can come up with our own
the uh they're they're in addition to
the the
the circle ones and the kind of weird
square ones that you said almost don't
look like a circle plus
or a square plus or whatever there's
also a uh triangle plus
minus times okay
um but not a whole lot beyond that
yeah there's weird stuff here
but we can totally invent our own
well so probably somebody's got to go
through here and figure out the next
20 reasonable operators to add
that'll be my suggestion
good for ken iverson he managed to get
apl symbols or he didn't get very many
of them
in there
okay let's keep going here
um
i think that was it for that first topic
yep
so people who are we're here for the
first topic if they
can drop um
have a great day okay see you guys
um
okay what's the example of an updater
right uh plus plus minus minus
uh pen two
a mutator just sounds like some kind of
weird biological
hoo-ha
an l-value i don't know um
well why don't we just call them
assignment based operators
what's wrong with that that's what they
do they do assignments
well but they they only assign the
things which already
have a value
right these are this this thing you know
what why don't we look in the version
one
mathematica book i bet i gave these
things a name
shall i look there can somebody else
look there
uh you can remind us
i can look if i can remember where to
find it
let me see if i can find it
it's a bit old-fashioned
um how would it be here
well somebody should find it here i
don't know i'm sorry
okay i think that the you know
the right thing to associate it with is
assignment because that's what it's
doing
what about resetters or reassignments
reassignment operators yeah reassignment
operators not bad reassignment
reassignment functions
assignment functions reassignment
functions
reassignment functions is kind of okay
assignment functions which you know it's
reasonable to think that reassignment
functions will be a subset of assignment
functions
that seems okay to me
okay byte count documentation the fact
the byte count of x is zero
and you don't need to update the dots
unless you haven't done it and
[Music]
seems okay but considered are treated
effectively
oh whatever that's okay
okay i can take care of
right did we did we make it through here
okay all right thank you all very much
see you later bye